FEMALE SPEAKER: Out there
would to ask questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to a special edition
of Google+ Developers Live,
part of the Google Developers
Live program.
We have a special show
for you today.
A special treat.
We have a new participant.
We have OSCAR, the Hangout
Robot, a brainchild of Gus.
GUS CLASS: So I'm Gus, and I'm
a developer advocate on the
Google+ team.
And, yeah, I'm really excited
to be here for Google
Developers Live.
And OSCAR is just a robot that
I dug out of my parents'
basement because I remembered
that I had it around right
when I was learning how to
create Hangout apps.
And so in an afternoon, I put
together a web server and then
connected it to the
Hangout app.
And so hopefully when you click
the commands within the
Hangout app, it will
move OSCAR.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
You see OSCAR moving.
And let's take a look
at how that happens.
We have some people joining
us through the magic of
cyberspace on the Hangout.
So why don't we introduce the
people who are joining us that
way, who will be helping
us control the robot?
So, starting with you, Emily.
EMILY: Hi.
I'm a software engineer.
I do web and [? concurrent ?]
and stuff.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, and you had
some really great questions
last week so you get to
join us this week--
GUS CLASS: It's a joy.
A bonus.
JENNY MURPHY: Or earlier
this week.
And next to you is,
of course, Gerwin.
GERWIN: Hi, I am Gerwin,
developer from Austria and I
love Hangouts.
I love robots.
So that's just perfect.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
So switch over to OSCAR's view--
what OSCAR's seeing.
Oh we can see Devin there.
DEVIN: Yep.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi, Devin.
He's our volunteer robot handler
who is helping us in
case OSCAR finds a way
to get out of frame,
like off the table.
Anyway, Gus, why don't you tell
us a little bit about
that interface the people
use to control OSCAR.
GUS CLASS: Sure.
So on OSCAR is just a--
there's a tablet that's
running a web server.
And then that web server has
some hooks that perform serial
communication to the robot.
And then in the Hangout app is
just an iframe that is the
target of four buttons--
one forward, left,
back, and right.
And clicking those buttons will
actually open the target
URL inside of that iframe.
And then the web server returns
a sensor record for
the bumpers, and the
wheel drop sensors,
and the cliff sensors.
And I'm not entirely sure
they're all working correctly
right now because of a
melting accident that
occurred with OSCAR.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
Legend has it that OSCAR had a
short career as a battle robot
that was not very successful,
as you can see from the
missing panels and
scorch marks.
GUS CLASS: Well, the other
robot was a lot bigger.
JENNY MURPHY: The other
one was bigger?
Yeah.
You should have seen him.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, you should
have seen the other robot.
So it's probably a great time
for us to play around with it.
You can see OSCAR move across
the table a little bit and
explore the studio.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
GUS CLASS: And there's Lewis,
who is our extremely helpful
engineer for video.
JENNY MURPHY: This is actually
your first chance to see the
studio in its entirety.
GUS CLASS: In its entirety.
Lots of cameras and
some box lights.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So Gus, what happens when
multiple people try and send
different commands of the
robot at the same time?
GUS CLASS: So what happens when
multiple people send them
at the same time, the web server
that runs on top of the
robot will just queue those
commands up and then execute
them as they came.
Something that actually we were
thinking about doing when
creating the initial version
was, instead of
just passing commands--
because when the commands
come in, they just send
acceleration values or motor
values to the two wheel motors
on the Roomba.
And what we are thinking about
doing instead is just sending
delta values.
So, for example, if it were
forward, you would send a
delta value of 100 left wheel,
100 right wheel.
If we were backward, it would
be negative 100 right wheel,
negative 100 left wheel.
And if it were right or left,
it would be positive on the
right side, negative
on the left side.
But actually, instead, if you're
just sending them delta
values, then if everyone clicked
at the same time, it
would just make their change to
the robot's current speeds.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Sounds like something you
might want to add later.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
Definitely a v2 very,
very early alpha.
I don't know, what comes
before alpha?
JENNY MURPHY: Prototype?
GUS CLASS: Prototype.
There we go.
JENNY MURPHY: Garage stage.
GUS CLASS: Garage stage.
Yes.
JENNY MURPHY: Something
like that.
Which OSCAR is definitely in.
Very sophisticated piece of
machinery that OSCAR is.
So I saw that OSCAR
in all caps.
Does OSCAR mean anything?
GUS CLASS: It does and the
acronym is hard for me to
remember sometimes.
But it's Overly Simplified
Collaboratively Actuated Robot.
JENNY MURPHY: Awesome.
It's a great name.
GUS CLASS: So can we let OSCAR
go around the studio
a little bit more?
JENNY MURPHY: Sure.
So we'll let OSCAR move around
the studio, and then we'll
take some questions from the
stream and from the Hangout.
So, Devin, if you'd
like assist us?
Devin is going to move the robot
to the floor to reduce
the risk of catastrophic robot
failure due to falling.
So you guys can explore the
studio in the Hangout.
GUS CLASS: It's a little
bit hard to see--
DEVIN: He's stuck again.
JENNY MURPHY: He's
already stuck?
DEVIN: It seems to
[INAUDIBLE]--
GUS CLASS: Is it the surface
that he's on?
MALE SPEAKER: He's on carpet.
DEVIN: I think it's
the controls--
GUS CLASS: So a technical
detail.
I'm using a tunnel that
actually has been
crashing all morning.
But it's a demo, and
we have fun.
JENNY MURPHY: It's one of the
interesting features about
controlling robots from a
Hangout is robots are, by
their nature, hardware
devices.
And Hangouts run inside
a web browser.
And bridging the communications
between the web
browser and a hardware device
is often an interesting
problem to solve.
And the way we solved it
with OSCAR was by--
GUS CLASS: By using a service
called localtunnel, and then
just kind of using that service
to map a global URL to
the internal URL
for the robot.
So it's a proxy.
And it's kind of a--
it should be reliable, but it's
really just kind of a
beta service that's
sort of a demo.
JENNY MURPHY: It's always an
interesting challenge.
GUS CLASS: Demo, demo.
We get about--
I think we've been getting about
five minutes at a time
on there, and I'm not exactly
sure why it goes
down when it does.
JENNY MURPHY: Great start for
pieces hobbled together from
your parents' basement.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
Absolutely.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Well let's answer some
of your questions.
So does anyone in the Hangout
have a question for Gus about
OSCAR, or for OSCAR, even?
I'll see if there are any
questions on the live stream.
So a lot of people expressing
their desire to meet OSCAR.
You've met him now.
GUS CLASS: Devin, would you
actually put OSCAR back here?
I want to make sure that's not
the web server that went down.
It could be.
JENNY MURPHY: We're going to do
some little poking around.
GUS CLASS: Some poking.
Hi, friend.
JENNY MURPHY: And no questions
from the community yet.
So if you have any questions,
this is a great chance to ask
us, or OSCAR.
GUS CLASS: OK.
So it is the tunnel,
unfortunately.
Which is strange.
JENNY MURPHY: So have we
inspired anyone out there?
Gerwin or Emily, do you
have any robotic
plans for Google+ platform?
GERWIN: Not yet.
JENNY MURPHY: Not yet?
Well, hopefully, get those gears
turning a little bit.
EMILY: I'd love to
see a Hangout
plugin for the AR drones.
GUS CLASS: Oh, yeah.
EMILY: Because they're
actually pretty--
oh, what's it called?
There's a term in cyberbotics
which has to do with things
that have recorded physical
behavior that lets you
basically--
instead of going, move all these
rotors in all of these
really complicated ways, you
basically just go, go left,
and it will figure out how
to do that for you.
So because it has that, you
could actually probably do
something very interesting
there-- by setting up a signal
bridge between the two.
JENNY MURPHY: AR drones and
other quadropcopters are
definitely something we have
tossed around the ideas.
We've talked about them
a little bit.
They are really cool
for that reason.
The APIs that are available
are pretty easy to use.
But we decided to start with a
terrestrial robot before we
went with the avian variety.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
EMILY: Yeah.
I can imagine it would be--
if the software were to crash,
it would crash in a very
particular and spectacular
kind of way.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
It might take out several
cameras as it goes out.
It would pretty cool, but--
GUS CLASS: And there's other
interesting problems, too,
like what happens when the
batteries get low?
It's flying and it's
got some--
JENNY MURPHY: Slowly lands.
GUS CLASS: Ideally.
EMILY: I think actually
it does have--
it is actually self-preserving
in that sense that
it will try to land.
GUS CLASS: Oh, that's good.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Well now that we have OSCAR, we
may investigate other modes
of robot Hangout
transportation.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
EMILY: Need more robots.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
So, yeah, absolutely, you could
create a Hangout very
easily with any robot that can
be controlled or actuated
through a web server.
And you could actually probably
even use my app.
So it's pretty simple and
there's like-- we have some
documentation online on the
inner workings of what it is
specifically, and the source is
going to be made available.
JENNY MURPHY: That's great.
So you mentioned that your
application might be reusable.
Can you explain how other people
might be able to use it
for their robots?
GUS CLASS: Sure.
So long as you have endpoints
that are currently-- it's just
forward, left, right, back, you
can just change that URL
to whatever your
web server is.
And so long as it responds to
those, you can just put
anything that can join a Hangout
on top of that, and
then you'd be controlling the
robot from a Hangout.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So if you want to see the source
code that we're using
to power that, we'll be putting
that into the same
repository that we put all of
our Google+ Developers Live
code in, the Office
Hours repository.
And it will be up there soon.
GUS CLASS: Yep.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
GUS CLASS: Great.
JENNY MURPHY: So thanks
a lot for coming
in to show us OSCAR.
Unless anyone has any other
questions, I think we'll
probably wrap it
up for the day.
GUS CLASS: Yeah.
Thanks everyone for
participating in
the Hangout, too.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you want to
give OSCAR another run around
the studio?
GUS CLASS: Unfortunately,
the tunnel went down.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
The tunnel went down.
Oh, we actually have some
comments from the stream.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
JENNY MURPHY: Could
you show OSCAR?
So we'd like to get a little
better closeup of OSCAR.
GUS CLASS: Sure.
JENNY MURPHY: Let's
see if we can--
GUS CLASS: And if it would help
for me to raise the robot
a little bit.
JENNY MURPHY: There.
You can get a really
good view of OSCAR.
As I mentioned before, a very
sophisticated piece of
mechatronics machinery.
Possibly the most advanced
Hangout robot in the world.
Maybe.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
And there's the back.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, the duct tape
is coming in version 2.0.
GUS CLASS: Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is actually using binder
clips at this point.
JENNY MURPHY: Cardboard, paper
clips, and binder clips.
GUS CLASS: Yes.
JENNY MURPHY: That's pretty
sophisticated.
GUS CLASS: Very sophisticated.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Well, with the closeup
of OSCAR--
GUS CLASS: OSCAR's closeup--
JENNY MURPHY: I think we're
going to wrap it up for today.
So thanks a lot, everyone,
for tuning in.
We will have more regularly
scheduled Office Hours.
We'll be on a regular schedule,
and hopefully we'll
have some more of these special
editions coming out.
So thanks a lot for tuning in.
And if you were waiting on the
stream, thanks a lot for your
patience as we got started.
Bye, everyone!
GUS CLASS: Bye, everyone.
Thanks for watching.